gamespot originally reviewed warframe in
2013 and gave it a six out of ten due to
substantial revisions and new content
since its debut we have re-examined
warframe as it is in 2019 and produced a
new review to reflect its current state
[Music]
in 2013 a sci-fi Luke Bryan starring a
cast of space ninjas was an inspired
concept in our original review we
praised the fast paced gameplay but it
was clear that warframe lacked
meaningful features that took advantage
of its strengths now in 2019 warframe
has evolved it's much more than just
space ninjas brawling in corridors it
takes a decidedly unorthodox approach
with its nonlinear adventure
sometimes frustratingly so yet
journeying across warframes massive
universe is as satisfying as it is
endearing throughout the sprawling
campaign you slash shoot and free run
through different missions with an
impressive amount of freedom to take on
different objectives there's a
staggering amount of activities to dive
into and with well over 40 hyper
stylized frames to utilize there's a
constant sense of fun and surprise when
discovering how deep it all runs to play
warframe can often feel like playing a
larger game of catch-up with six years
of content but it's a game that
definitely rewards patience as most
missions are set on standalone levels
across the star chart the games
piecemeal structure ultimately makes the
massive game more digestible
despite its growth over the years
warframes roots are still firmly planted
in its fast-paced and satisfying combat
which is intuitive enough for newcomers
to dive into the overall speed and
flexibility in its action are excellent
and there's a constant sense of grace
that can make even the ordinary missions
thrilling giving way to the most
gratifying and stylish encounters the
true star of warframe are the various
frames with each one possessing its own
traits and abilities it always feels
rewarding when you find a new frame
especially ones that are highly
specialized these include the stealth
oriented ash the aquatic alien tentacle
summoning hydroid and the bard like
Octavia who can craft music to amplify
your abilities and attack enemies you
have free rein to experiment with unique
frames and it can be especially fun
strengthening them with powerful mods
and armaments that can melt through
enemies it's also impressive how
in-depth customization is in warframe
and it's rare to find another player who
has your same style and loadout while
the core combat is often satisfying it's
still common to see a streak of highly
repetitive missions most of which
recycle assets for procedurally
generated levels and objective types
this repetition can create a recurring
feeling of deja vu and there were times
when this left me feeling exhausted
after an extended session warframe does
try to inject
a number of variations to mix this up
though some missions Accor per 8 the use
of the archwing switching up the
familiar action sequences with deep
space shooter levels there's even a set
of PvP game types such as the Conclave
and duel modes with the latter letting
you invite another player to a clan dojo
to engage in a solo fight but when
compared to the PvE experience the
competitive activities come across as
exceedingly basic and clunky warframe
takes a mostly hands-off approach in
getting you in the rhythm of cutting
down mobs of enemies and boosting your
frames strengths by collecting mods
however this can sometimes create
feelings of aimlessness which is
magnified when it becomes apparent that
there isn't a traditional end game to
work up to warframe is a challenging
game to crack if you're committed to
figuring out the intricacies of the game
then using online guides to understand
its in-depth mechanics as a must these
resources are a big help but is
disappointing how often yet to use them
as opposed to the game itself teaching
you the same information without them
learning these systems on your own can
be a significant test of patience
fortunately warframe does have an active
and open community to seek assistance
from and you can directly interact with
others at various social spaces across
different planets stick with the game
long enough and you'll unlock access to
the more involved cinematic story
missions and open-world settings which
left me wanting to invest more time to
continue interacting with warframes
characters in the plains of idolan and
the orb palace you can take in the
sights at the large-scale worlds engage
in dynamic bounties and events with
squads and even learn more about the
brewing conflict within each setting the
valises stories especially engaging
dealing with workers rights and the
perils of late-stage capitalism in the
interstellar age I'm continually pleased
with the flexibility of warframes many
systems and how it allows for you to
attain a variety of rewards at your own
pace of course there's an assortment of
items weapons and even frames to
purchase with real money or platinum
warframes premium currency fortunately
most items in the game are attainable
through gameplay allowing you to get
into the nitty-gritty of the games
content mostly unabated the economy of
warframe is very active and if you're
resourceful enough you can even trade
some of your own gear and blueprints
with other players for platinum as well
when new content is introduced the
pathway to experience in the quest or
acquiring the next frame is available to
all players this relaxed approach is
reassuring especially for a game of this
magnitude and I generally found
acquiring gear and new classes to be
quite manageable however there's still
some time sinks that feel mostly
arbitrary resulting in the expected and
sometimes lengthy grind that's
commonplace in free-to-play games to
that end the primary intent of platinum
is to circumvent both investments of
time and resources
it's interesting how much warframe is
improved yet also how much has stayed
the same over the years though it still
has issues with repetition and lack of
explanations for its more complex
systems it's managed to overcome their
severity by introducing so many events
and revisions that continue to elevate
the game
there are some expected bouts of
frustration to be found but I always
manage to Center myself once I move on
to other opportunities in a lot of ways
that's what warframe manages to do best
just when you feel like you've hit a
lull a better and more fulfilling
opportunity will likely present itself
perhaps most importantly warframe makes
sure that the time spent in its world is
almost always well rewarded
you